gibson's rangers debut and his 3-2 pitch
swung on and missed strike three there's
his first rangers strikeout two away
second and third
one and one
this is bounced to third connor frelefa
bro gets away from frasier martay is
home here comes escobar the rangers
throw it away and it's two nothing
diamondbacks
kyner falefa has looked so good in
summer camp that he won the third base
job
which made the move frazier across the
diamond over to first and that
combination something went wrong right
there here's the pitch to peralta and a
shot to center and that ball will sink
for a base hit walker turns third he's
coming to the plate the score is offline
he scores
an rbi single for david peralta and it's
three-nothing d-backs merrill kelly
who's looked good in his summer camp
appearances last year his first in the
majors after four years in korea and
merrill was among the most effective
rookie pitchers in the league
swinging a miss and merrill has his
first strikeout
swing and a miss merrill kelly two
strikeouts and a one two three first top
of the order now and shinsu one two
pitch
breaking ball strike three call to the
outside corner amero kelly chalks up his
third strikeout he's got a one two three
third inning daryl kelly has not given
up a base hit yet and danny santana the
center fielder leads off the rangers
fourth
here's a shot of the ground
walker a nice diving stop on the flip in
time tomorrow kelly there's nick gold
glove potential at first base walker
took it away from santana one out yeah
gold glove play right there that ball is
heading into right field backhand dive
comes up makes a nice throw right to
merrell that's perfect it's number 50
from merrell kelly on the way
wing and a miss that's four strikeouts
rangers have been no hit to this point
tonight
and andrews with a liner that's caught
by marty to win the inning
smoke to be right at marte for the final
out one two three go the rangers for the
fourth time in five innings it's up to
stephen vogt
who has grounded the second and struck
you out
both down the line that's a fair ball
it's in the corner walker's home and
it's four nothing
stephen votes first hit as a diamondback
is a two out rbi double
nick ahmed at shortstop bobble behind
the bag what a recovery and they can't
get connor filetho the slick fielding
shortstop nick ahmed
has committed an error here will rudd is
the official scorer the pressure's on
him but
i don't see how he could score that a
base hit and here is shinsuchu the left
fielder
so kelly for only the second time
tonight is out of the stretch
avenues six ground ball to second marta
domit to first double playing the
innings over the no hitter is intact
merrill kelly
six and a third in with a pretty decent
pitch count
75 [ __ ] right now oh door hammers one
deep out to right gone
and the rangers
get that first hit of the game
and it counts for a run oh doors first
round tripper of the season this is one
two to frazier
got him swinging the ball sells by
kelly and that's a strikeout number six
on the night for merrell kelly as willie
calhoun leads off the eighth
oh two to calhoun a swing of the miss
strike three stanked out one away
another nice pitch in the dirt breaking
ball
seven strikeouts now for merrell kelly
two two now
ground ball up the middle ahmed can't
get to it
and andrews is aboard i'm not sure of
anything but i would think this might be
his last hitter and that base hit into
left field is probably going to seal
that deal
back-to-back singles in this eighth
inning
here comes the tying run a couple of
base hits here
and they've got a legit shot
so jose le cork i wonder probably in the
game no matter what but i will see if
the rangers take the lead certainly or
even tide would be
in the game
off the handle popped up in field fly
rule in effect
two gone outstanding performance by
merrill kelly tonight now bring it home
merrill has left andrew chaffin some
work to do here
two on and two out the dangerous
shinsuchu is the hitter 3-2 on the way
got him andrew chaffin with a big slider
and he strands to merrill kelly
outstanding there's no one between
second and third base in the infield
joey gallows swinging a miss archie
bradley comes in and strikes out the
side the two three and four hitters in
this rangers lineup and locks it down
for merrill kelly who was an absolute
superstar here tonight